[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
12 major differences between the harry
potter books and films the film
adaptations made quite a few adjustments
to what we read in the books and we're
just going to take a handful of the big
ones and present them for you guys for
those of you who are new myself and star
wars theory and rate these videos so if
you hear two different voices in these
videos
that's why without further ado here are
12 major differences between the harry
potter books and films let's start with
number one peebs the poltergeist peeves
is perhaps the most infamous poltergeist
of Hogwarts
he has existed at the school since its
inception and his character appeared in
every book he was a troublemaker in
seemingly every capacity but somehow
didn't make the films he was a constant
annoyance to the school's inhabitants
particularly to Filch the part of peeves
was actually filmed and he was portrayed
by actor Rik Mayall but his parts were
eventually cut from the franchise never
making it to the theaters number two
nearly headless Nick's death Day party
in Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets nearly headless Nick who haunts
the Gryffindor Tower invites Harry Ron
and Hermione to celebrate his 500th
death Day party this party was put on by
Nick to commemorate the day that he died
though Hermione Ron and Harry were
invited the rancid moldy food would have
likely gagged a living person many
interactions between Hogwarts students
and ghosts were eliminated in the film's
number three
Rita skeeters secret Rita Skeeter is the
most infamous journalist of the Harry
Potter franchise known for spilling the
beans on witches and wizards and
capturing intel that one might consider
to be hard to come by the film's glossed
over entirely was that Rita Skeeter was
actually an animagus meaning she
possesses the ability to transform
herself into an animal and back again at
will Skeeter's and omegaz form was a
beetle allowing her to easily spy on the
subjects of her stories this covert
physical form allowed her to create the
most scandalous and
full articles number for the Dursleys
goodbye it's no secret the Dursleys are
awful too hairy and they pretty much
always have been throughout the books
and films the Dursley show harry time
and time again what they really think of
him however what people who have only
seen the film's might not know is that
there was actually one shining instance
of the Dursleys showing some form of
compassion to harry and it was from none
other than deadly in one segment of the
deathly hallows deadly actually shakes
Harry's hand corrects Harry and tells
him that he doesn't think that he's a
waste of space and even gives him a
genuine see you Harry before they part
ways beautiful number five double doors
past Dumbledore is a massively layered
character with a rich past a past that
was not covered at all in the films
outside of the last movie sure with
fantastic beasts now in theaters we are
getting to know a bit more about
Dumbledore but the books that long
preceded those movies contained a ton of
Dumbledore his backstory as well in the
last movie Harry learns a bit more about
Dumbledore but in the books we learn
about Dumbledore's family the death of
his sister Ariana and other
relationships knowing a bit more about
Dumbledore's character from the books
definitely helps you to understand
Dumbledore's character in the film's
number 6 Battle of the Astronomy tower
in Harry Potter and the half-blood
Prince Malfoy is sent by Voldemort to go
and assassinate Dumbledore Draco sneaks
and other Death Eaters to support his
mission via vanishing cabinets in the
Room of Requirement in the film after
Snape kills Dumbledore nothing really
happens and there is no battle in the
book
however battle ensues between the order
of the Phoenix Dumbledore's Army and the
Death Eaters number 7 oh yes my personal
favorite Harry did you put your name
into the Goblet of Fire this is of
course referring to a massive Liberty
taken in the Goblet of Fire from
adaptation where Dumbledore asks calmly
if Harry put his name into the Goblet of
Fire the film adaptation of this scene
was much more over the top this
Dumbledore was of course played by
Michael Gambon who took over the role
after the death of Richard Harris while
many blame Gambon and give him a hard
time for this in reality it was really
the fault of the product
Asian team gamblin simply delivered the
line as he was told to do so number
eight Harry and Ginny Ginny and Harry
have seemingly no chemistry or intimacy
in the films despite them eventually
getting together the books hinted their
relationship on numerous occasions which
eventually results in the start a
relationship at the end of the
half-blood Prince the films do an awful
job at hinting at the relationship and
the only time they show intimacy toward
one another is only kiss in the Room of
Requirement the books also portrayed
Ginny in a different light she was more
than just Ron's little sister who
followed them around because she liked
Harry she was a genuine friend to the
entire group and a crucial character in
the books who added a layer to the story
the film production team just didn't
capture number 9 Filch is a squib Argus
Filch is everyone's least favorite
caretaker nobody likes him the main
reason for this being that he spends
most of his time trying to catch
students breaking rules while Phil shows
almost no compassion or emotion in the
films the books do paint him in a
slightly different light it is revealed
in the books that Filch is actually a
squib meaning that he comes from a
magical family who does not possess the
ability to perform magic this is
explained in the following excerpt from
the Chamber of Secrets and what on
earth's a squib said Harry to his
surprise Ron stifled a snicker well it's
not funny really but as its Filch he
said a scrip is someone who was born
into a visiting family but hasn't got
any magic powers kind of the opposite of
Michael born Wizards but scribbs are
quite unusual
if filchers trying to learn magic from a
quick spell course I reckon he must be a
squib it would explain a lot like why he
hates students so much Ron gave a
satisfied smile he's bitter this
actually makes you feel a tiny bit of
sympathy for him and sort of helps you
to understand why he is the way that he
is he was born a non-magical man into a
magical world which I expect would be
exceptionally difficult and while I
don't feel that he actually hates the
students he does love to give them a
hard time which is supposed we can just
let him
laughs number 10 Slughorn Horace
Slughorn former potions master and
former head of Slytherin house is a
Hogwarts staple one issue was cyclones
adaptation in the films is that his
character looked nothing like the way
that he was described in the books when
his character is introduced in the
half-blood Prince Slocum is described as
been very short very fat very old very
bald and having a moustache that may as
well have belonged to a walrus in the
films
Slughorn who was played by Jim Broadbent
shows none of these physical
characteristics this is not necessarily
a big one as he does a great job but it
is an inconsistency nonetheless
additionally the relationship between
Slughorn and Harry was significantly
watered down in the film adaptation in
the book the relationship is a lot more
complex especially Harry's end it's the
type of relationship that you'd have
with an older relative with whom you
didn't quite see eye to eye but you
still like because you know that they
mean well in the movie Harry seems to
feel a bit uncomfortable from time to
time but he doesn't seem to care as much
about some of the things that upset him
in the book while I enjoyed Slughorn's
portrayal in the film it didn't have the
same substance as the book number eleven
Voldemort's red eyes this one's pretty
straightforward in the books walden is
described as having red animalistic eyes
in the films they went a pretty
different direction with this as they're
just white and pale blue it was later
revealed that this was a conscious
decision as those working on the film
felt that giving him red eyes would
remove too much humanity from his
character but it wasn't just his eyes
Voldemort's appearance in general was
off he was supposed to appear almost
serpentine but in the film he really
just looked like a bald man with no nose
Voldemort is still scary-looking and I
can understand where they came from with
this decision but this is a massive
inconsistency as far as the books are
concerned and lastly number 12 we have
Harry's eyes now this last one is
something that many took issue with I am
of course talking about Harry's eye
color Harry or the Boy Who Lived is
described as having bright green eyes
the books but what we saw in the films
were the natural blue eyes of Daniel
Radcliffe while filming Radcliffe had an
aversion to using contacts this meant
that his natural color would have to
suffice Harry's eyes are said to match
his mother's on various occasions in
books and films but his mother's eyes
are never addressed directly it is only
mentioned that her and Harry shared the
same eye color when Snape was dying he
begged Harry to look at him so he could
stare one last time into the eyes of the
woman he loved but in the films Harry's
eyes did not resemble his mother's both
characters are meant to have green eyes
but film Lily's eyes were Brown and
Harry's were blue I think that not
matching their eye color was a massive
oversight particularly because Harry's
eye color has mentioned a fair bit and
that's it for this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you guys want more videos
like this then just let us know down in
the comment section below we were
thinking of making a video series that
breaks down the differences one book at
a time let us know if you'd like that
until next time your or was it Harry
[Music]
you